he rolled out of the White House and
rolled in to what sounded very much like
campaign mode
versus Joe Biden's State of the Union
Address scripted like a CV for a second
term
because the soul this nation is strong
because the back broken backbone of this
nation is strong because the people of
this nation are strong the state of the
union is strong
join us tonight are the parents
Tyree Nichols the parents of Tyree
Nichols a black man beaten to death by
police officers how'd the president call
for police reform just as every cop when
they pin on that badge in the morning
has a right to be able to go home at
night
so does everybody else out there
our children
have a right to come home safely
he spoke change two in weapon ownership
a 26 year old hero when he introduced
Brandon say who disarmed a gunman in
Monterey Park California following a
mass shooting band assault weapons now
ban them now
once and for all on the Republican
benches they won't talk cheering nor did
they when the president spoke of turning
around the economy uniting the country
and calling on his opponents to work
together
unlikely for some Joe Biden held that
when he addressed the controversial
matter of raising America's debts here
this political set piece was a platform
for a presidential run Joe Biden has
said he intends to seek a second term in
the White House there are strong hints
of an announcement soon
thank you
those remain about his age and capacity
but in this performance Joe Biden came
out punching every inch a one-term
president pitching for a second
James Matthews Sky News in Washington